what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing future for Humanity the
commission has decided to find Google
4.34 billion euros
this is your man on the moon moment we
are innovating here and we hope that you
like it
long live Europe
welcome to Europe calling a series of
podcasts brought to you by the European
commission looking at the politics and
policies of the union today with me
Stephen Jones and me Paul Anderson and
today we're focusing on Russia's
invasion of Ukraine the hard realities
on the ground as experienced by
ukrainians who've succeeded in fleeing
bombardment and Siege the response by
the European Union to the emergency
relief that ukrainians have needed in
their country and in the neighboring and
nearby countries where millions of
refugees have fled to medical support
food water clothes Safe Haven there are
also The Wider issues at play here
sanctions unlike any others before the
question of Europe's dependence on
Russian energy supplies and the future
defense and security of Europe a warm
welcome to all our listeners and a quick
disclaimer these interviews were
recorded prior to news of atrocities by
Russian forces around Kiev and prior to
their visit by commission president
Ursula Fonda lion to the Ukrainian
Capital to express the eu's support for
Ukraine olena alexieenko is a Ukrainian
Refugee from butcher Northwest of Kiev
she arrived recently in Belgium with her
two teenage children what was your
immediate reaction Elena when Russia
invaded Ukraine what did you do
at the beginning I was in shock
I didn't know what to do with my
children to escape the bombing
immediately we turned the basement of
our house into a bomb shelter
we moved everything we could from the
house down there and I just sat there
with the children terrified
we thought that it might be over in just
a few days because that's what people
were saying
that it would be over in a couple of
days
that only military locations would be
bombed
no
um
how did you begin trying to escape from
Ukraine
it was very difficult to get to the
buses
I don't know how many people were there
maybe one thousand two hundred maybe a
thousand that we counted on the first
day
we waited but then the Russian occupiers
would not allow us to leave the next day
we could go
on the way to the bus we had to take
different roads
we had to change our route twice because
of the military hostilities
what were your thoughts at that point
it was very frightening to go in these
buses because everyone said the Russian
occupiers were firing at these buses
carrying children and people but I went
at my own risk and decided that if
something happened I would protect my
children with my own body
you eventually reach Slovakia on
Ukraine's western border and you then
traveled through Europe through the
Czech Republic Germany and finally to
Belgium how have you found the
experience of being in Belgium
it was a wonderful surprise to
experience how people have welcomed us
here when we arrived in Belgium
I could breathe a sigh of relief calmly
we were welcomed like family by hosts
called Pierre and Marie who have three
children of their own
they gave us two rooms
we could all live there peacefully
the fed us and gave us clothing because
we arrived with nothing nothing at all
just the clothes we were wearing
they helped us with filling in forms and
documents
they propose different activities for my
children
during the weekend they did cooking with
the children
I really like the attitude of Belgian
people towards ukrainians
they are very kind people
many thanks and we'll come back to you
for some more thoughts before the end of
this podcast
let's turn now to mache popovsky acting
director general for neighborhood and
enlargement negotiations in the European
commission mache popovsky what is your
assessment of the most urgent emergency
and humanitarian priorities in Ukraine
given now that part of the Russian
strategy appears to have changed from
all-out assault on cities to Siege
Warfare reports from Mario Paul suggest
it's being starved into submission
actually we've seen it before we've seen
it in Aleppo
so of course it means that the
humanitarian Anita are really depressing
and then there is this huge population
of internally displaced people 6.5
million people on the run in the country
and they need to be looked after it's
actually amazing that giving the
circumstances the Ukrainian government
is working pretty normally in a way they
defy all the pre-war cliches about the
Ukrainian statehood because they are so
robust we are in touch with the
Ministries every day and they are very
responsive very agile so what what's
really important is to give him a
Lifeline what sort of lifeline
the European commission together with
European Investment Bank we've been
providing them with liquidity with cash
because they need cash you know to
function normally to pay pensions to uh
pay for doctors Etc so we have provided
them with what we call macro financial
assistance which is a loan but a quite
an attractive loan of 1.2 billion so 600
million we've already paid and 600
million is yet to go and and the
European Investment Bank have they have
provided uh close to 700 million and
we'll top it up with 120 million in in
Grants so that should keep them afloat
for a while and then we'll have to think
further because the needs are so
enormous how practically is Aid being
delivered on the ground in Ukraine of
course we have to be extremely Vigilant
we have a number of harps coordination
hubs uh close to the border so one is in
Poland in Jesus there is another one in
Slovakia and another one in in Romania
so everything is going there and being
channeled into Ukraine and for the time
being Road and rail transport works well
another uh difficult to talk about
success stories but something that is
encouraging uh is the use of the Union
Civil protection mechanism so this is
this network of member states plus
countries like Norway and turkey and
they deliver Goods which which
ukrainians now need like power
generators medical devices even digital
equipment you can call it a big
humanitarian Amazon you can order
whatever you need and it's being
delivered in no time
right at the very beginning of this war
there were deep misgivings about
Russia's honoring of humanitarian
corridors is there anything that the
European Union is doing or can do to
shore up those humanitarian corridors
given potential needs in the future and
also the vast number of internally
displaced people that you were referring
to earlier on
it's a trick or not the stream
um people leaving from marupal and and
other places usually whenever the
Russians allow for humanitarian
corridors they close them themselves
they after and I think it's it's done on
purpose just to destabilize people even
more but then actually the the reception
in the EU and the movement of people the
temporary protection that they've been
offered by by you is is working very
well the commission has made a very uh
ambitious proposal of
um
putting together a big Financial package
for Frontline member states like Poland
and Romania to be able to to cater for
the needs of the refugees and schooling
and healthcare because the the numbers
are so uh so huge and it's working so um
people are being being looked after
mache popovsky many thanks indeed and do
please stay with us a reminder that you
can get tons of information in Ukrainian
Russian and English on various EU
websites key in EU stands with Ukraine
or EU solidarity with Ukraine to get the
eu's main information and news
destinations we also invite you to have
a look at the support group for Ukraine
set up by the commission and the website
of the EU delegation to Ukraine which
holds a truth of information
next let's hear from Save A Lot chance
of Ukrainian ambassador to the EU on the
Ukrainian perspective to some of these
issues Ambassador a warm welcome to you
what's your view first of all on how the
EU has been supporting Ukraine so far EU
in general is doing really a lot and
this is tremendous help also sanctions a
fifth package of sanctions both sectoral
but personal including companies what is
important in that regard that there are
no loopholes in the regime like it was
the case with the Crimean sanctions and
Russians and also European companies
they manage to circumvent and find their
ways to get the machinery and other
products and even Investments to Crimea
and my understanding is that both EU and
partners like United States they're
looking into that issue so on one hand
to reinforce the sanctions but on the
other to make sure they work properly
you meant mentioned another package of
EU sanctions but has the EU sanctions
regime against Russia gone far enough
what more could be done on reducing for
example the import of Russian oil and
gas
definitely there is a space to work
harder to hit harder Russian economy and
we are talking about disconnection of
all Russian banking system from Swift we
are talking about Energy Products like
oil and gas we are talking about Russian
ports we are talking about broader
Maritime industry we are talking about
Road Transport so we need to disconnect
Russia
from the rest of the world let's talk
about military assistance from NATO and
the EU is this help enough for Ukrainian
forces to hold the Russian military at
Bay we understand there is Article 5
NATO is not ready to to get engaged
directly with Russia in a military
conflict but we need this help either
military help and we we asked to close
the skies or at least to provide us with
a serious weapons that we are able to
stop this assault from the air from the
sea so that we are ready with our forces
to withstand this increasing pressure
because Russia tries to engage Belarus
Russia tries to bring new resources from
Russia there they are not waiting
they're they're getting prepared for the
new massive assault so that's why we we
need this support right now are you
worried that as the conflict drags on
the eu's collective will could be
undermined by some member states whose
relationship with Russia is stronger
than others this is a moment of truth
it's moment of black and white now for
many member states including those who
are more dependent on on Russia to make
their choice because Ukraine is
suffering but suffering not only
defending Ukraine but defending All
European Union right and EU and member
states have to sacrifice some things to
sacrifice their comfort to look for
alternatives to work hard but not just
to build the wall saying no it's
non-starter it will be too difficult yes
it is difficult but they have to do it
Ukraine has made a formal application to
become a member of the EU but that's
been your aspiration as a country for
many years are you confident the mood
across the EU has changed sufficiently
now in your favor on this issue it's
being processed within the system
already so the necessary decision I've
been taking so now it was moved from one
table in the council to to the table in
the European commission we expect that
European commission will prepare its
opinion about Ukraine's Readiness to
become a member this is a important
stage but what is procure normally it
takes even to move between those two
tables the paper several months sometime
almost a year sometimes they never move
the the those papers but now uh it's
days and weeks rather than months and
years and my feeling is that there is a
Readiness in the European commission to
move really fast
and work hard Ambassador sevillaud
chensov thank you for sharing your
perspectives
now mati masikas is head of the EU
delegation in Ukraine which has recently
moved back to Kiev after operating for
several weeks from just across the
border in Poland
could you paint a picture for us first
of all ambassador of what your
day-to-day work is like at the moment
days are long and intense of course but
obviously
the best that we can currently have
a part of this growing and increasingly
tight-knit community and it helps us to
coordinate our International support
efforts to Ukraine how are you managing
the distribution of humanitarian Aid
humanitarian assistance despite of all
the difficulties are delivered all over
Ukraine even in hard to reach areas
humanitarian Aid is provided and
distributed by trusted humanitarian
partners
like ngos our Ukrainian
partners and
the UN agencies they have good expertise
and experience how have you adapted the
work that you were doing in Ukraine
before the war to meet the challenges
that Russia's aggression has caused
until Russia's unprovoked and
unjustified invasion of Ukraine the
European Union was predominantly
focusing its assistance on supporting
the government
in its ambitious reform agenda which is
based very much on the association
agreement
with the EU that there's a full-scale
Invasion the European Union has
immediately taken measures
in order to allow for repurposing most
of its interventions about 100 million
euro is already available
through ongoing projects
immediate emergency assistance like
basic Goods food shelter and sanitation
kits and Equipment but also protective
equipment helmets bulletproof jackets
are being
provided
farmers are supported to secure in the
coming cropping season
we want to make sure that Ukraine can
replenish its food stocks and enhance
its capacity to expert agricultural
products
issues such as protection of the
civilian population is already
also addressed and in particular
children affected by the war
at the core of our attention
and what is the EU doing to support the
government in Ukraine
the EU also continues to support
government's resilience
through technical assistance and
specific equipment
this has allowed the government to keep
most of its Ministries and agencies in a
working mode
cooperation with local Administration
has been increasingly strengthened they
are playing a crucial role in
coordinating this dispatch
and distribution of humanitarian
assistance do you see any Avenue for a
ceasefire and advancing peace talks if
so what we support all genuine and
meaningful efforts
to bring end to the war
and we recall our position Russia must
stop its aggression
and withdraw all its forces from Ukraine
respect Ukraine's Independence
sovereignty territorial Integrity within
its internationally recognized borders
how important has it been to have so
many volunteers from all over the EU
supporting Ukrainian refugees who've
been forced to flee to bordering
countries Poland Hungary Slovakia and
Romania principally the mobilization of
Europeans coming to help their brothers
and sisters escaping the Russian
invasion he is unprecedented people are
coming to the board to help some as part
of
various organizations some privately on
their own
some stay a few days others stay for
weeks we are observing comprehensive
truly popular movement of solidarity
and of course also further away from the
youth border people opened their homes
to ukrainians mati masikas EU ambassador
to Ukraine thanks a lot for your time
now let's turn our attention to economic
questions and Gennady chichakov you're
president of the Ukrainian Chamber of
Commerce and Industry in Kiev currently
in Belgium first tell us what effect
this war is having on businesses in
Ukraine Figures it's a little bit
different but in general we need to
understand 30 percent of Ukrainian
business stopped nearby 50 percent
working partly time to time Etc military
activities in 10 regions these regions
are very important for economy of
Ukraine this is industrial religion
focus on uh agriculture sector a lot of
experts estimated their input of this
region in the general economy were like
50 of GDP you can imagine 50 of GDP it's
obviously a devastating effect on the
Ukrainian economy but what sort of
knock-on effect is that having Beyond
Ukraine Ukraine always was uh and is is
very much uh export oriented country
well we are number four in the world
like agriculture sector we played a very
important role in the Steel Industries
in many others and for example in the
agriculture sector we produced a minimum
five times more than we needed for you
for Ukrainian that's why Ukraine it's
not only a bread basket or Euro but
probably it's a bread basket of all the
world and we know how many countries
depend on our activity first of all the
country of the Northern Africa Middle
East and many other countries who are
depends on our corn wheat sunflower oil
how effective do you think efforts have
been to discourage Western businesses
from continuing to operate in Russia do
you think the message has got through
enough yet
I asking my friends from abroad
businesses but that's a deadline when
you decided to leave your Russia you
needed occupied one country two
countries free country you you still
didn't understand first sign was 2008
Georgia second one 2014 Ukraine Crimea
donbass 22 is a real aggression full
aggression of Russia against Ukraine and
some people still can't you see no we
needed to find some compromise this is
not a war this is a special operation
guys I will buy the ticket to you please
take a train go to give go to the
mariopal and see and after where come
back and say no this is a special
operation and we needed to find some
agreement no and what's your vision for
the economy of Ukraine When The War is
Over honestly speaking in Ukraine all
Ukrainian absolutely sure first we will
be winner in general second Ukraine will
be very popular like example who
protected the peace protected democracy
and to be to walk and to cooperate with
Ukraine it will be very not only popular
but it will be very important if you
would like to do something you can knock
into Ukraine can I walk with you if you
don't have a business in Ukraine nobody
knows you this is my answer to you I
absolutely believe in the bright future
of Ukraine we lost a lot but we will
find a lot first of all friends and
support of all the world
thank you for your comments
Machi popovsky acting deputy director
general of DG near thanks for staying
with us relations with the eu's
neighbors is your daily work and Ukraine
which has an association agreement with
the EU ahead of what it hopes will
become full membership is one of the
biggest neighbors how much does kiev's
current response reflect the eu's values
given that historical memory from the
second world war is beginning to fade
but will nonetheless forever be the
basis on which the union was founded the
spirit of never again now being
rubbished by Russia Ukraine is standing
up for Europe's core values and founding
principles here is it not true true and
you know we should I mean we do realize
but we should also be vocal about it
that ukrainians are fighting and dying
for our values I mean it's it's serious
and this level of motivation is simply
incredible
and I think that exactly the opposite of
what Putin wanted to achieve it's the
consolidation of the one hand Ukrainian
statehood and on the end on the other
hand the uh so the consolidation of
Ukrainian Society whatever language they
speak and wherever they come from on the
question of sanctions what is your
assessment of their bite so far
we do think that half of the assets of
the Russian Central Bank Frozen so they
don't have access it's 300 billion euros
roughly and then of course the different
measures restricting trade cutting off
Russian Banks from Swift but most of
them and you can see it I think that
that many Russians in particular in the
big cities were in a State of Shock when
for instance the credit card companies
just decided to withdraw so there's a
lot of examples of that kind and of
course now we are really determined to
reduce and phase out our dependency on
the Russian gas and oil it will not
happen overnight but commission made a
proposal to reduce it by two-thirds I
mean when it comes to gas by the end of
the year which is huge we certainly have
to do it because we don't want to
continue funding the Russian war chest
by the way it was also quite interesting
to see um how the myth of the Russian
Invincible Russian army basically fell
apart and and the impact of the
sanctions will be felt there as well
because they don't have access to modern
technology what if cracks appear as many
say they did after sanctions were
imposed following the annexation of
Crimea in 2014. the sanctions need to be
sustainable in the long run and we have
to make sure that there is no
circumvention and I think so far so good
actually colleagues dealing with
instructions in the commission tell us
that there is over compliance so a lot
of companies that don't didn't have to
leave Russia did so for political and to
some extent also moral reasons and and
if you decided to stay and continue
business as usual in in a way you become
a pariah let me ask you about the issue
of Ukraine's aspirations to join the
European Union you mentioned credit you
mentioned gratitude that the European
Union owes Ukraine for defending our
common values to what extent does that
extend to finally giving Ukraine a very
clear and unambiguous perspective on
becoming a member of the European Union
now the ball is in the commission's
court so we were asked to prepare an
opinion on the application but we know
that um it's not business as usual but
we're not starting from scratch Ukraine
is a good example Dave
um they've been implementing their
Association agreements together with the
Free Trade Agreement entered into force
in 2016. so we are working on it now and
it's a as a matter of priority
thank you for your comments and at this
stage as we come to the end of this
special podcast on Ukraine let's give
the last word back to olena Alexander
who fled Ukraine with her two teenage
sons and is settling into a new life
with a host family in Belgium Elena what
does the future hold for you do you ever
think that far ahead
I don't know what to say
well I'm still in shock over here this
week
I need a moral space for what I have
gone through
many people have said to me I understand
what you're going through
but no you don't understand
you weren't there in the middle of it
all
you didn't see it
you didn't hear it you didn't feel it
you didn't stay in a room where it was
only eight degrees
you didn't have to place Furniture in
front of your windows so the bullets
wouldn't hit you
you don't understand these things
and for the moment I don't know what is
the future for me but I know I want to
return to my land to rebuild my state
are you able to receive news about your
loved ones still in Ukraine
I'm still in contact with family and
friends who are still in Ukraine
I'm also in contact with my grandmother
who's 82 years old
and is an invalid and can only move
around the house
so the neighbors are looking after her
she said I should take the children and
leave Ukraine
but is in Kiev now as it is quieter
there
people went where they could to
different places
well that's it from us for now our
thanks to olena alexianco who you've
just heard to Sarah chenson Ukraine's
ambassador to the EU Ambassador mati
masikas head of the eu's delegation in
Ukraine tomache popovsky acting director
General in the commission and to
Ukrainian businessman gennadykov
you can listen to this special edition
on Ukraine and all previous editions of
Europe calling on all good podcast
platforms but for now from me Paul
Anderson and from me Stephen Jones
goodbye goodbye
what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing future for Humanity the
commission has decided to find Google
4.34 billion euros
this is your man on the moon moment we
are innovating here and we hope that you
like it
long live Europe
[Music]